if you told me five years ago that today
I'd be delivering a talk about our
individual power to make a difference I
would have cringed it was my job to
study huge global systems I was a
researcher at NASA using satellite data
to study the big picture you can see a
lot of things from space like every
ecosystem on earth being threatened from
pretty much every angle and global
inequality in air and water safety and
these kinds of things would keep me up
at night and then outside of work I'd
used this bird's-eye view while thinking
about our huge social structures like
education and media and healthcare and
it looked to me like they were all
really struggling too so I felt like the
world was just trapped in this huge self
amplifying system that was just
spiraling towards destruction and of
course I wanted to do something about
this and I felt so small and utterly
powerless but I started to feel a little
differently as my perspective shifted
from the macro towards the micro it
began with bumblebees I was using
satellite imagery and field research to
study these amazing cute pollinators and
to see how they were doing in the midst
of their own environmental crisis in
Southern California and from the macro
view I saw 22 lane freeways endless
suburban sprawl and water being diverted
from parched rivers to grow lawns in the
desert it was pretty grim but on the
ground there were actually some small
opportunities for optimism these tiny
patches of resources known as habitat
fragments if the right kinds of plants
were growing along the edge
of a Costco parking lot and if in the
neighborhoods nearby there were native
plants in people's gardens and in the
canyons that were too steep for people
to put their suburbs in there were
native plants instead of grasses then
all of these in between spaces would
actually add up to create a network of
habitat fragments and this network meant
that the bees could traverse through the
concrete desert feeding from and
pollinating the native plants and these
plants that the bees depend on and that
the be sustained are essential they
stabilize our steep hillsides they
provide food and homes to thousands of
amazing species of animals and
critically they're helping to curb our
devastating cycle of wildfires by
preventing the growth of those invasive
invasive grasses that fuel the vicious
flames that were all too familiar with
it's a really vital and interconnected
system and some people could see how
they were a part of it and so they acted
as habitat fragment they planted native
plants in their yards and they even were
tending to the land in corporate parks
and in public canyons and in my research
I could actually see the impact that
even one passionate gardener could make
and then repeated across the region
their habitat fragments for adding up to
make a more resilient ecosystem not not
a perfect system not by a longshot but
at least a system that was less likely
to totally collapse under impending
pressures like further development and
drought so I was looking at the world
through this lens when I found myself in
the waiting room of a public hospital in
Brooklyn with my partner Charles and we
were sitting across from a group of
teenagers who were slumped in their
chairs and bored out of their minds and
just refreshing their phones over and
over again and in the neighborhood was
some of the lowest high school
graduation rates in the city this
waiting room felt like a social habitat
fragment to happen so we did some
research to see what kinds of resources
could we add to spaces like this one
that would make an impact and we settled
on museums museums are the most trusted
source of public information more than
the media and more than the government
but they also cluster in wealthier
neighborhoods New York has 85 museums in
Manhattan and the Bronx has eight even
though these two boroughs have almost
the same size population and then
expensive tickets mean that a lot of
people can't go to museums even if they
live nearby and these little and
justices they just go on and on and they
add up to create sweeping inequalities
in knowledge and empowerment across the
u.s. almost 90% of visitors to art
museums are white and even at the
Smithsonian's network of free museums
almost half of their adult visitors have
graduate degrees which like ten percent
of the broader population has so it
became clear to us that even though
museums are these amazing educational
and social resources they're not
reaching everyone and a lot of museums
are aware of this and they're trying to
change it but there's all these
structural hurdles that are slowing them
down so we set out to create a
distributed network of museum habitat
fragments working from a donated
shipping container with the volunteer
help of our friends and dozens of very
generous scientists from all across the
globe we built our first prototype the
smallest mollusk Museum mollusks are
these tentacled slimy shapeshifters like
oysters and octopuses and the giant
squid and if you've ever seen an alien
in a movie then I'll bet you it was
inspired by a mollusk they're slimy
sci-fi vibes make them really fun tour
guides for a biology museum and they can
teach us about the system's out we all
share with a wake up call
of all the animal extinctions documented
since the 1500s more than 40% have been
our friends the mollusks so we tested
this museum across the city to see if it
resonated with all kinds of visitors
and it did people really liked learning
from it so we built a fleet of tiny
science museums each one small enough to
fit into preexisting locations with
information dense enough that they could
still pack a punch and their modular so
they can be distributed at a scale that
can reach everyone and then we partnered
with libraries and community centers and
transit hubs and the public hospitals so
that we could transform their in-between
spaces into habitat fragments for social
learning and fittingly we named our
fleet of museums micro even though each
habitat fragment is small it provides
the essentials it draws people in so
that they can explore and learn together
in a social way and then distributed
across the landscape were able to invite
people everywhere into conversations
around science when we partnered with a
public hospital in the South Bronx we
became the Bronx's first and only
Science Museum yeah that's really weird
uh-huh and really quickly families
started coming by with their kids and
schools started arranging field trips
all to this tiny Museum in the front
lobby of the public hospital and the
museum became so popular that we started
hiring local students to be museum
docent so they could lead tours and the
activity is for all the talented kids
and every spark of curiosity that were
able to fuel and each new fact learned
and every new friend made at the museum
and every kid who can have a meaningful
and important after-school job
it all contributes to a stronger system
so today I try to keep the micro view in
mind I'm always examining how small
actions can add up to create shifts at
the macro scale of systems and honestly
I'm seeing a lot of really good things
there are habitat fragments everywhere
nurtured by talented passionate
strategic individual
and groups of all sizes who are building
towards systems with more equal access
to food and employment health care
housing political empowerment education
and healthy environments one by one
together
we're filling gaps strengthening the
systems that were all a part of we have
to work on the big institutions too of
course it's just that they're so slow
and we're living in the midst of rapid
change it's a defining feature of our
time so maybe in some cases our small
actions can be band-aids until the big
guys catch up but without us what are
they going to be catching up to am I
still scared about the world yes that's
why I'm talking to you
the world needs so many more habitat
fragments so if you've been feeling
overwhelmed or powerless lately then I
am asking you to please try this very
small strategy on for size and let's see
how it goes step 1
zoom in it's not one huge system that's
just barreling unstoppably towards
destruction what we have are many
overlapping systems and the ways that
they interact determine everything step
two look for the resource gaps because
that's where you can make the biggest
difference and do some research to
understand how your ideas are going to
interact with the systems that are
already on the ground step 3
find the other habitat fragments find
out how they can support you and how you
can support them because we're building
a network together in step 4
transform your fragment you might not
have the leverage to change multiple
systems at once but there are so many
small meaningful and strategic things
that each of us can do and there are a
lot of us so it will add up thank you
[Applause]
[Music]